hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys will's
vor kurzem lieferte beitrag auf galileo
da habe ich ja kraut feder rezepte
gemacht also rezepte die man gut
vorbereiten kann die schnell gemacht
sind die günstig sind mit wenigen
zutaten am besten und mit denen man mit
wenig aufwand viele menschen glücklich
machen kann und dazu gehörte auch ein
riesen coupé und zwar ist es ein
amerikanisches rezept und ihr kennt ja
alle diese cookies von subway die sind
ja so groß und schön weich und ich
verliere liebt diese konsistenz und die
konsistenz kommt dadurch zustande weil
einfach viel fett und zucker mit drin
steckt deswegen sind die nicht so wie
zum beispiel ausstehe plätzchen die zwei
auch fähigkeit und viel zucker aber eben
nicht so viel und jetzt mache ich heute
diesen riesen coupé das werde ich in
einem wrack rahmen zu bereiten und hat
mir einen großen coup der dann wie
kuchen stücke geschnitten wird und
später zum beispiel mit 1 regiert wird
ich zeige euch jetzt mal die zutaten für
den riesen coupé brauche ich zwei der 50
gramm weiche butter 100 gramm braunem
zucker 200 hinweisen zucker mit dem
salat etwas an extrakt zweier die zimmer
waren sind 300 gramm mehl 1 teelöffel
backpulver 300 gramm shopper trotz und
seiner drei männer ja also das wie
gesagt es ist ein fettiges und süßes
rezept mir persönlich also mir ganz
persönlich ist es zu süß ich würde
wahrscheinlich die zuckermenge um die
hälfte reduzieren
aber dann habt ihr auch nicht mehr die
typische cookie konsistenz das heißt
falls ihr es nicht so süß haben wollt
könnt ihr gerne den zucker halbieren
aber falls ihr die cookie konsistenz
frei behalten möchte dann solltet ihr es
zu lassen
und ich habe es auch beim galileo dreht
so gelassen und es hat wirklich jedem
super geschmeckt dass nur dazu gibt's
nehmt ihr die weiche butter die sich
zutaten sollten punkt als zehner von
seinem also bevor
alles andere sei sowieso zimmer war die
kommt jetzt in einer grün maschinen oder
ihr wird das ganze mit einer handvoll
gerät dann beide zucker sorten und den
braunen zucker nehme ich wollte einfach
so ein bisschen nerven malzirkels
karamell artiges aromat das passt immer
ganz gut als jetzt aber keinen brown zu
gehabt oder nicht bekommt könnt ihr
natürlich weglassen und durch den reisen
sogar austauschen dann die prise salz
mit ryan und vanille extrakt und jetzt
wird das etwa 12 minuten training
floriert
jetzt kommen sie auch noch nacheinander
dazu und geht es also um etwa eine halbe
minute mit berührt werden
backpulver miteinander dann kann sich
das backpulver gut im meer verteilen
die sich jetzt in einem schwung mit dazu
ob damit der teig kurz fertiggerichte
und währenddessen kommen jetzt noch viel
foto stückchen mit rein
fast alle aber so eine handvoll lasst
ihr noch die sträucher nämlich oben
drauf
hab ich hier den fertigen teig der ist
in der konsistenz natürlich sehr fest
also eigentlich ist es ein normaler
rührteig nur bei einem rührteig wird mir
jetzt noch mit zufügen dabei eben etwas
resigniert jetzt kommt die hälfte davon
in meine vorbereitete form und david
bakradse auf ungefähr 28 cm eingestellt
und wasser bitte unter gelegt um das
ganze auf den pisten sind und um den
teich zu verteilen nehmt ihr am besten
entstehen mit etwas wasser bevor ich das
eure hände und streicht den teig mit den
fingern platz dann klebt nämlich an den
fingern und es geht einfach schnellsten
jetzt kommt dass nutella an die reihe
davon gebe ich 200 gramm in die mitte
oder haben wir später denkt okay dem
teller gefüllt ist
und kam gar die frage auf heißt sehr sie
oder das hotel firma sagt ja der modelle
aufstellt dass nutella glas oder jeden
teller drehen
jetzt kommt die restliche menge drauf
also ich hab dessen dass nutella jetzt
übrigens nicht ganz bis zum rand
verstrichen
mainz noch der teig trübe kommt jetzt
die finger wieder etwas befeuchten und
das nutella gut abdecken
jetzt kann ich noch die restlichen
schokostreusel drüber verstreuen
das sind übrigens backfest schoko drops
und die sind ja wirklich ganz typisch
okotie nun von patienten übrig und jetzt
kann der kugel gebacken werden und jetzt
wird der kuki im vorgeheizten backofen
bei 175 grad für etwa von 30 minuten
gebacken
er sollte in japan das fürchten
der cookies gebacken und ich habe ihn
auch bereits aus der trockenen form
herausgelöst jetzt schneide ich die ein
stückchen ab und danach studieren aber
herz auch vielleicht ein bisschen
man sieht sich die konsistenz ist jedes
wahnsinnige das ist wirklich das
richtige ist so eine richtige cookie wir
vielleicht aus aus den ganzen
amerikanischen fast food ketten kennt
man aus also unten die kugel schüchterne
teller schicht und ich fand jetzt das
ist super reduziert ja ein bisschen aber
ich finde so lecker aber es natürlich
von dem galileo dreh von ich denn
richtig cooler sein was man will leoni
nicht dabei war dieses konditorei ske ja
das ist jetzt cool
natürlich ist wirklich ist eine sehr
sehr süße speise als eine kugel die
kalorien mit nicht zählt
also ich muss ehrlich sagen ich war es
ok noch leicht warm ist und dann für den
ich mir ganz sicher dass ich sehr sehr
viele menschen die nicht jetzt hier bin
ich
eigentlich
kuhlmann gefallen tut einem rezept mal
nichts ändern macht es einfach mal so
wie es ist wirklich echt klasse schön
weiß aber nicht wegen kuchen und dieses
stück also dieser kuchen dieser kopie
reicht auf jeden fall für locker 20
leute also wirklich ganz locker und dann
noch so ein päckchen
dazu wird ein vanilleeis gewählt weil
ich finde es fast geschmacklich sehr gut
dazu oder fahrstufen ich könnte euch mit
sängerin auch du mir leid aber erstmal
ohne spaß dass ich wirklich ein riesen
cookie der schmeckt wirklich sowie die
aus diesen bösen leben
aus diesem bösen fastfood-läden weg ich
gehe ja auch immer kann schon mal hier
mache ich dich rein halten
der show genial nach machen wollt geht
auf meinem blog this blog de auf jeden
fall ist es ein richtig tolles kraut
feder rezept oder für richtig viele
leute einmal den aufwand gehabt und dann
könnt ihr was kunst an so einem ding
irgendetwas gern überlegt man es in
münchen sitzt 20 20 20 und 30